whatever happens in iowa in 274 days
you the american people you will render
what is the ultimate verdict
president trump he will be acquitted on
wednesday and the latest impeachment
with
witch hunt which will be dead the power
to decide
our future now rests squarely in your
hands ultimately the ultimate jury
you can in 274 days as i've been saying
shocked the world again
and the democratic party state-run media
the mob there
they have nothing to offer except what
they've given us for three years
conspiracy theories lies smears slander
hoax after hoax what is an unhealthy
obsession with russia russia ukraine
ukraine and peach and peach
and meanwhile the democratic primary is
shaping up to be yet another
massive dumpster fire like it was in
2016. look at this
socialist bernie sanders has now surged
into the lead
and the democratic establishment in a
state of shock and panic
you have those associated and friendly
with uh barack obama
with the clintons the so-called
mainstream democrats
everywhere seem to hate bernie sanders
have over there chris matthews
and others on the conspiracy theory
channel msdnc
openly worrying now that no democrat can
beat trump john kerry reportedly
overheard
telling someone that bernie sanders
could take down the entire democratic
party
he first said expletive on twitter then
he deleted the expletive tom brokaw
thinks
that it would be really hard for the
people to vote for bernie's brand of
socialism
tom with all due respect a little secret
here they're all radical extreme
socialists
read the new green deal and you might
want to look at medicare for all and how
did that obamacare thing work out
2016 democrats well they did their best
to rig the primary against bernie
sanders in fact remember
interim dnc chair donna brazile
discovered that the clinton campaign
and the dnc had in fact been working
together to defeat bernie throughout the
primary in other words the system was
rigged
according to brazil quote she had
exerted this control
of the party long before she became its
nominee meaning hillary clinton and now
history seems to be repeating itself
the dnc is changing the rules so that
one of bernie's top challengers may be
bloomberg or whoever else
can then take the debate stage without
meeting requirements
bloomberg meanwhile is probably one of
the dullest human beings alive he's
best known for being a 12-year caretaker
of mayor giuliani's accomplishments in
new york and luxury new yorkers on how
much soda they can drink and how much
salt they can use
he's a strong advocate by the way of
giuliani's successful stop and frisk
policy for 12 years
but until recently here we are seven
years after that
now bloomberg yes identity politics and
full play running for president
had a sudden change of heart he has to
now play nice with the identity politics
platform so he's pretending to be
devastated that for 12 years and then
seven years after that that he ever
supported stop and frisk
but while bloomberg is a obvious
hypocrite bernie's long-held views are
downright scary that is true now here's
what the president had to say in our
exclusive interview take a look
well i think he's a communist i mean you
know look i think of communism when i
think of bernie i think of bernie sort
of as a socialist but far beyond
the social elizabeth yeah wedding
honeymoon
let's see the former soviet union
doesn't really go together
wants to nationalize health care with
medicare for all he now has a plan to
nationalize the entire
energy industry we just became energy
independent for the first time in 75
years the lifeblood of the world's
economy
he just unveiled a 16 trillion dollar
climate change plan
now keep in mind total budget really
take in about
four trillion a year uh that's every
penny
we'll have nothing left over for things
like oh defense
and by the way like any good socialist
bernie doesn't think
any of these rules apply to him look at
this report
sanders now leads the 2020 field of
democratic radical socialist
environmentalist new green dealers in
private jet spending
now let's just talk about one of
bernie's well
his search he's probably the only
democrat running who actually
excites the base we know that quid pro
quo
joe for example has inspired virtually
no one he got 75 people in iowa recently
at an event
he's struggling to raise money his
events barely draw a few dozen people
his biggest cause for concern surrounds
a scandal that won't go away
biggest loser in this latest hoax well
boomerang back on
quid pro quojo and zero experience
hunter and joe leveraging our money
yep a billion taxpayer dollars you're
not getting it unless you fire the
prosecutor you got six hours
so his son can keep getting 83 grand a
month
most americans family of four average
about fifty four thousand dollars a year
uh
in case you didn't know zero experience
hunter no
experience in oil gas energy or ukraine
why would any company pay
somebody like that oh let's see millions
and millions of dollars it is now clear
hunter wasn't selling experience he was
selling access and it looks like it's
paid off
because in 2015 then vice president
biden threatened to withhold that
billion
and guess what son of a b they fired the
prosecutor
and he bragged about it now he's not
bragging anymore in fact he's getting
quite angry and unhinged whenever the
subject even comes up
like it did with savannah guthrie take a
look
this process of impeachment has ensured
that everyone knows about hunter's
dealings with ukraine that's a good
thing and no one's found anything wrong
with his dealings with ukraine except
they say it
sets a bad image do you think it was
wrong for him to
take that position knowing that it was
really because
that company wanted access to you well
that's not true you're saying things you
do not know what you're talking about
no one said that he's a very bright guy
i guess the question i'm kind of asking
is
was it right his appearance yeah yeah
well he said he regretted having done it
he said it you're not getting the
billion unless you fire that guy
investigating my zero experience son he
has no answers
because there is no reasonable
explanation selling
access is what was going on and using
our tax dollars to do it
ironically every hypocritical democrat
and every media mob individual that
failed to do what savannah guthrie did
take a bow great job
and the biden family business the
syndicate was churning a massive profit
every step of the way
voters have every reason not to trust
him and by the way
his front runner status is in jeopardy
tonight without a doubt this is the most
radical hypocritical
and corrupt democratic field in modern
history and extreme
and as the president pointed out this
election it's going to have
dire ramifications for our kids and our
grandkids
take a look if they were to win
based on maybe the new green deal
medicare for all
what would you see america becoming
they're going to give away
things that are impossible no oil and
gas
they're going to they're going to stop
energy production that
wipes out texas and many other states
they're going to get rid of your second
amendment
but here's the one thing i've always
heard cut taxes cut taxes great thing
cut taxes
they want to double and triple your
taxes they want to quadruple your taxes
they want to take everything away from
you
if they get in it all collapses and you
know what's going to happen
people's wealth whether it's big or
modest or whatever it is
you'll end up in a recession depression
like we've never seen before people's
wealth will be destroyed
as i said you're the ultimate jury in
274 days you can shock the world